in one of your tweets you listed out
some of the things you should study like
programming sales
reading writing arithmetic
one of the items that ended up on the
cutting room floor was that you should
also study ethics i was originally going
to put that out there as a concession to
people who believe that making money is
evil and that the only way to make it is
evil but then i realize ethics is not
necessarily something you study it's
something you think about and it's
something you do every one of us has a
personal moral code and where you got
that moral code from is different for
everybody it's not like i can point you
to a textbook sure i could point you
some roman and greek text but that's not
gonna certainly make you ethical there's
the golden rule right do unto others as
you would have them do unto you or
there's nasim teleb silver rule which is
don't do unto others which you don't
want them doing unto you once you've
been in business long enough you will
realize how much of business is about
trust and it's about trust because you
want to compound interest you want to be
able to work for long periods of time
with trustworthy people without having
to re-evaluate every discussion without
any rethink each time and without having
to constantly look over your shoulder
and so over time you gravitate towards
working with certain kinds of people and
similarly those people will gravitate
towards working with other ethical quote
unquote people so being ethical turns
out to be a selfish imperative you want
to be ethical because it attracts the
other long-term players in the network
and then they want to do business with
you and if you build a good enough
reputation for being ethical eventually
people will pay you just to do deals
through you because you're the one who
will validate and insure the deals by
your presence because you wouldn't be
involved with low quality stuff
so being ethical actually pays off in
the long run but it's the very long run
in the short run being unethical pays
off which is why so many people go for
it it's a greedy algorithm but you can
be ethical simply because you're
long-term greedy and i can even outline
a framework for different parts of
so-called ethics just based on the idea
of long-term selfishness for example you
want to be honest because it leaves you
with a clear mind
you don't have two threads running in
your head one is a lies that you told
you to keep track of and the other one
is what you're saying you just have to
think about one thing at a time so you
have more energy to think about that
thing so you're a clearer thinker also
by being honest you're rejecting the
people who only want to hear the pretty
lies so you force those people out of
your network and sometimes it's painful
like friends and family but long term
you create room for the people who like
you exactly the way that you are so that
is a
selfish reason to be honest for example
in negotiations if you're the kind of
person who
always tries to get the best deal for
yourself
you will win a lot of very early deals
and it'll feel very good but on the
other hand there are a few people who
will recognize that you're always
scrabbling and not acting fairly and
they will tend to avoid you over time
those people end up being the deal
makers in the network because people go
to them for a fair shake or to figure
out what's fair and so if you are
cutting people fair deals you don't get
paid in the short term but in the long
term everybody wants to deal with you
and you end up being a market hub you
have more information you have trust you
have reputation and people end up doing
deals through you a lot of wisdom is
just realizing the long-term
consequences of your actions and so the
longer term you're willing to look the
wiser that you're going to seem to
everybody around you
uh
probably a huge portion of why i'm so
ethical is because of self-interest
enlightened self-interest
so i think i think what what people
don't realize is
most things in life
function on trust
uh they don't function based on
contracts
they function based on trust
and and
so
if you
if you become
very trustworthy
it gives you a massive
competitive advantage huge leg up in
life
and
the thing is that this trustworthiness
doesn't come overnight but it's it's
kind of like on a log scale so once you
uh it's like kind of like truthfulness
right i mean you sometimes yourself
small lies but if you eliminate all lies
you know the powers of force we've
talked about
what happens is that
you know those attractor fields come
into play
and uh
humans
the humans
feel they can trust you
and once humans feel they can trust you
the whole universe is at your disposal
so
we see that in spades in berkshire
hathaway you know berkshire hathaway
does all kinds of things where
they just say something to someone and
people will accept that
they don't need to have it in writing or
anything like that it just warns word is
enough
and and so uh how do you get there
well
you get there by having a consistent
life
where you are
have demonstrated repeatedly
that you are
you know
playing playing the game very ethically
uh playing the long game and
looking at things
to make sure that your business partners
and vendors and whoever you deal with
is treated extremely well you know
ray kroc used to say that there were
three stools
on which mcdonald's stands he says
he says my franchisees
my
vendors
and my employees
right so the franchisees were all
entrepreneurs right they they owned the
and he felt
he had to make sure that they did really
well
the people supplying the french fries
and the cups and the plates and all of
that at mcdonald's
ray kroc wanted to make sure they did
really well
so he's not trying to squeeze them for
the last penny he wants them to do well
right because he says that it's part of
my ecosystem and i have taken those
those lessons to heart so like you know
if i have a relationship with a printer
for my business
uh
i want those relationships to go on for
decades i want the printer to do well i
don't want to be squeezing him
every time and get three quotes and take
the lowest and all of that i don't want
to do it that way you know i want to
make sure that it's fair and and we
don't need to go to multiple courts we
just
run our business
on trust
and uh and so what happens is that when
you show trust in
uh in a company or a human being they
react really positively
so my baseline when i'm dealing with
anyone my baseline is that the other
person is a very high quality person or
a very high quality company and i can
completely trust them
then i wait to see if they do stuff
which violates that trust if it does
violate the trust
we'll move on you know we'll do
something else but i think when you up
front demonstrate the trust
a lot of good things happen so so i
think this this notion of being ethical
uh
running things properly
uh gives you such a tailwind in life
that it's you know like i think peter
kaufman says
if crooks knew how much money you could
make by not being crooked
they would stop being crooks you know
because basically you make a whole lot
more money by being honest you make a
very little bit of money by being
crooked you know so it's it's it's a
complete no-brainer
to be ethical and honest you know if
i'm in in my last book i wrote about
the morality that emerges from games
there's a neuroscientist who you might
be familiar with yak pancep who studied
rat behavior in games and he showed that
if you pair two male juvenile rats
together the one with the 10
body weight advantage will pin the other
almost 100 percent of the time
and you might say well what that
demonstrates is that might makes right
the
the stronger animal wins but if you pair
them together repeatedly after the first
bout the defeated rat juvenile has to be
the inviter of play in the next match
so
he'll invite the bigger rat to play
but over paired
over repeated pairings unless the big
rat lets the little rat win about 30
percent of the time the little rat will
stop inviting him to play
right so what happens is that you get an
emergent morality which is
not the ability to win any given game
but the ability to repeatedly play a
multitude of games and there's something
in that that's very much like what you
wrote about in in the origin of virtue
and something very much like a complex
reciprocity
right so
where where you store your good behavior
in your reputation essentially and that
that's of great advantage
yeah and and there is this you know very
very simple thing that was happening in
the 1990s when i wrote that book which
was
uh the people were playing the prisoners
dilemma game on computers and finding
out which strategy worked and the
prisons dilemma game is is is simply um
a game in which if if you
if if both players agree to remain
silent then they benefit each other but
you can make a bigger gain by by
betraying the other one but then if he
betrays you as well you both end up with
nothing so you've got to find a way of
reach of trusting each other enough to
cooperate you're being held in separate
cells and interrogated separately is the
sort of story that's being told
and um
it turned out that the best strategy in
a repeated business dilemma game is
uh
tip for tat
that is to say be nice
first time around cooperate on the first
play and then simply do whatever the
other guy did on the previous play
um uh so as to uh
punish or reward the other guy for
behaving badly or well
right so you're not a sucker with using
that strategy you're a cooperative but
you're not a sucker
yeah
and
and and in a sense we are engaged in
iterative
repeated prisons dilemma games all the
time you know you don't say well
i'm not gonna
uh bother paying for this loaf of bread
i'm just gonna grab it and run
um because then i'm better off because
then you can't go back to the shop the
next day
um yeah you'll be recognized by the the
police if yeah so it's morality as the
shadow of the future in some sense right
and again this all comes back to adam
smith i think because his his previous
book his book in 1759 not the wealth of
nations but the theory of moral
sentiments
seems to me to have a very profound
insight in me and it's taken a long time
for me to understand it and that is that
morality isn't as it were taught to us
by priests and other people it's
essentially a calculation by us
as to what works in the society we're in
and you kind of calibrate your behavior
to find out what is moral what is
ethical and so on and you know 500 years
ago the the right ethical thing to do
when somebody snubbed you was to um you
know challenge them to a duel and run
them through with a sword um well that
doesn't get you very far today
uh so you we've learned that actually
you you that we've
we've evolved
a higher form of morality um
uh sort of gradually by by standing back
and saying
in this society what's going to get me
the best rewards
given how other people are behaving
because of course everything
everything's a moving target it seems to
me too that that's deep enough now so
imagine that the landscape that human
beings occupy is a social landscape but
it's a social landscape that extends
across time and we've been conscious of
that for a long time at least 150 000
years so that's about when we changed
into the genetic
we changed genetically into the
subspecies that we are now
[Music]
you